[Music]
thank you for being here coming to see
documentary with subtitles means that
you are very special you're in the right
place there is the this is the only
place to be in New York today I want to
ask you first of all about your return
to documentary for because that's where
you started uh I love
documentaries I mean in the beginning
when I started doing film I started do
the short film and I thought that
fiction is
impossible uh because uh um it's uh it's
a lie and I can't uh you know uh so I
started doing documentaries and
then learning with documentary um gave
me the possibility to do fiction
documentary is different it gives you
the you need to be humble you know it's
not it's not you your thoughts your
ideas your it's about people's life so
I'm keeping going to
documentary be because it's uh a place
where I can experiment things when I I
can learn a lot to use this uh uh
knowledge in uh in fiction um I know the
story ala story with her daughters as
famous in Tunisia but tell us a little
bit about how you decided to make a film
about that I've heard the story of Ulan
interview on the radio you know we see
at some point some archives uh of olula
telling the story of her daughters on TV
it was in 2016 she was talking about her
daughters all over the media and I
thought this is incredible because I
want to know why those girls those young
people are attracted to
this maab thing you know I had the idea
to do a documentary because I thought
that the character is bigger than life
full of contradiction she have this uh
ability to tell her story in a
fascinating way she's a born Storyteller
and her daughter also they have this uh
they are very funny telling me horrible
stuff when I was nominated for an Oscar
I met a lot of people willing to work
with me and asking me what is your next
movie and they was telling them it's a
documentary in Tunisia was like are you
crazy you can't do this you know with
the nomination you have a lot of
opportunity um but I I was like if I
don't do this movie and I don't uh um
tell it in a way that can translate all
the complexity and the
Copic side of it anyway so yeah it was
challenging me so I was thinking about
this cliche of
reenactment which I hated and I thought
that maybe I can hijack this cliche
because you know each C say once uh it's
better to uh start with a cliche rather
than to end with one you know or
something like
this it seemed like yeah this is the
perfect way to tell it and even we
couldn't Finance this project before
with ola's story you know and when I had
this uh device let's say everything went
very quickly you know how did um casting
hand sub enable her to open up crack
crack open a little bit more and you
know interrogate that past and ask
questions about that past how did she
ended up trust trusting this actor I
know she's a famous actor in Tunisia so
tell us about that time Dynamic actually
it was Ula who gave me the idea to cast
this actress oh this actress there was
Tunisian movie about the mother she was
playing the part of the mother going to
Syria to look for her son so Ola went to
the movie theater because she was
interested in the subject and so uh this
movie so she told me ah you are a
filmmaker you know if we do a movie it
will be better than H sa's movie you
know this
actress one thing that you know struck
me as very interesting that you know you
have the actors obviously for the
daughters and to play Alpha but you have
one male actor to play all the men in
the story and it's almost like the men
in their lives obviously are
interchangeable they've done bad things
or they're kind of at the background was
that the thinking in casting one actor
to play all these roles I was thinking
about uh uh how to uh make it
simple you know because I have a lot of
female character I have a a gallery you
know right with the absent
one so uh and since I the movie take
care of saying who and who who playing
you know so I told myself if I have to
introduce a new actor for every male
part let's make it simple take uh one
guy and uh hope it will work so and it
it works on so many different layers
having just one actor um I'm wondering
if I mean there's this really twing
scene where the daughters are talking
about you know sexual abuse and they
don't name it that but you know we get
the sense pretty quickly um what were
some of the maybe ground rules that you
had amongst yourself when you know
something was too much for them when did
you know um that you were allowed to
film something versus not what were some
of those rules that you had I I trusted
their courage and uh I think the actor
reacted because they don't know them and
he was afraid because he can't it's not
his job you know he's an actor so
hearing those uh things so that's why he
uh went out out out of the scene but it
was really amazing to see uh Aya this
girl reassuring us adult around her
telling us I need this scene you know
it's I I I am over this story I I told
this
to so so many times so tell him to come
I really want this scene on the movie so
it was I mean her courage and strength
that that gave me strength you know to
uh uh keep this scene in the in the
editing at uh at the
end one of the things that's just so
complex you know about the story and
also you know women who have grown up in
sort oppressive cultures like like ala
did is the concept of patriarchy you
know it it's it's a tool to victim women
obviously but then you also see that her
adopting some of the rules of the
patriarchy and then enforcing those onto
um you know of her daughter so I'm
wondering when you're depicting this how
do you manage to stay you know kind of
nonjudgmental of your characters and
allow them to be who they are so that
you can capture their truth Ola is a
strange character because she's a strong
woman she don't uh obey to men or no she
she's she beats men you know it's like
but she's this kind of woman who
patriarchy for her it's a uh an idea you
know and she's uh like uh the guardian
of the this uh tradition you know in a
very vicious unconscious way you have a
lot of women you know they are defending
the patriarchy even more than men it's a
way to survive because she was raised in
a very poor and violent U neighborhood
and she survived because she was acting
like men so this is was very fascinating
idea for me to explore in this in this
movie and I want to talk a little bit
about some of the influences that you
might have had I'm wondering if you had
any movies maybe like the kirami movie
at the back of your mind as you were
constructing this yeah sure I mean the
day I saw closeup it was like a
uh changing moment for me in my career
as a filmmaker I was like this this is
possible to do this in cinema one of the
greatest movies I ever made so uh I also
watch uh Robert Green movie uh Kate
plays Christina I watched all the
because you don't have a lot of movie
like this you know so I watched
everything I watch it also I I was in m
center for documentary I watched great
Garden for the the daughter mother
relationship you know crazy relationship
so I had a lot like lot movies like like
this I what I watched Al I watched The
Act of Killing of uh Joshua
Oppenheimer um yeah I mean I watched a
lot of things far or close to what I
wanted to do I'm wondering if you have
any Reflections on what what this
process might have meant for the
daughters and for alula because they're
digging through some really painful
truths yes they're giggling about it at
certain points but it gets more intense
as we go along what are your Reflections
about those as I said I was scared all
the time uh about all those question you
know so we talked a lot before the
shooting but you know they are very
smart they enjoyed it actually I
underestimated the therapeutic aspect of
telling uh your own memory you know I
was really Amazed by the fact that this
movie gives the possibility to the
daughters to tell stuff to their mother
you know because they felt protected in
a way in this uh you know environment
that we created with the crew which was
mainly feminine crew very caring we
tried to create safe place so and ulab
she have this like as I said very um
repressive way to talk to her daughter
she she don't hear them you know and it
was really amazing to see them changing
you know during the shooting
and uh understanding especially Ola
understanding stuff about her life and
about what how she was brought up when
they saw the movie I was also scared to
death you know that was my next question
what did they say yeah they loved it I
mean even Ula she she was telling me
yeah I know that I'm horrible but you
manag to show more than this than my
horrible person you know so she was like
uh happy about it she like it you know
and the daughter even more she they were
like thank you for making our voice
giving us a voice you know because they
don't have a voice with their mother
they don't have a voice at all you know
and then we went to can the the movie
was in the main competition so it was
crazy to have Ola and her daughters and
all the actors on this red carpet in the
lumere theater with 2,000 person
watching this story it was just amazing
thank you for this conversation and for
your beautiful powerful and very
original film it's Tunisia submission
this year to the Oscars and I'm keeping
my fingers crossed for you thank you so
much
[Applause]
cter